[Music]
in books our knowledge noon
oh that's news even the phone book read
a book [ __ ] read a book member I saw
Lil Jon that shows don't submitted by
Canada loves Jacob oh you love Canada we
love you too land of Tim Hortons Hunger
Games helped a 12 year old girl save her
friend while playing outside 100 I
thought she was gonna volunteer as
tribute so this girl she's playing with
her friends in this thing called a marsh
here's no inversus I know cuz I don't
know that that's what I'm saying
go is it like a swampy yeah looks like
this
yep okay there's no mosquitoes there
yeah so Megan is 12 year old she's the
one that you turn ology from The Hunger
Games to help her friend who got a 10
inch long three inch wide gash in her
leg on the line by playing in the in the
marsh so family affair
so apparently like the group of girls
they were all playing in the mud but
then one of them had said that they left
their shoes like we're in a higher
ground and so when this girl she went
over to get it she ended up slipping and
she like Scott cut with the super metal
that was like somewhat in the work of
all rusty yeah I hope she got a tetanus
shot it's like this big oh yeah three
inches by Pantages just like the top big
it is like a side of it then Megan she
was able to grab something to like me
create like a tourniquet and that's what
she has she got particle sticks no she
got um like a piece of clothing in the
shoe is important to get wrap it it's a
rabbit mm-hmm does she plan a lot of
pressure so when yeah just stop the
bleeding or like to reduce the blast oh
that's cool we can learn to
entertainment like that ah that's so
true
so you having there the girl I watch so
much Baywatch growing up and I was like
that's how you CPR who's Susan Regan 12
Megan Wow my god she's a linebacker
that's crazy they do not look like 12
nah they look like high school girls
yeah well does she look like she could
throw down dude left type luckily she
was able to save her friend from
bleeding out that's dope
oh man too bad the shows I'd be watching
lately they only know they only teach
you how to kill they don't teach you how
to save to go how to hold nothing man
well maybe if you get caught for murder
you could like reference the book or you
know what I do know one thing though if
you get hit with an arrow just leave
that [ __ ] just break the arrow don't
pull it out break it out again
yeah just break the arrow off throw the
way the the quiver part or whatever the
end part and it just leave it in you
until you go to the hospital or
something I want to learn how to shoot
it early Lawrence Anderson who's larger
I understand the guy that holds the
arrows in his hands while I go I think
he could shoot I believe it was like it
was about taking something like seven
arrows in a second Loras was managed to
shoot three arrows in 0.6 seconds he
could backflip while shooting an arrow
and hitting target oh my god it's
amazing to [ __ ] your real-life ninja
yeah he's been studying for years though
it's not something that he got in like a
year it was like like counting like five
or seven years away he probably doesn't
have a girlfriend I would probably have
a lot of a girlfriend yeah that's big
that's the goal you know guys they learn
a lot of skills cuz you know they don't
have time and they don't have good looks
or whatever and then they become really
skillful and then they get a girlfriend
you know just look at large sanderson
and you'll see this guy just walk past
with the [ __ ] bow and arrow now mind
you he looks like he's never seen
daylight or human being but I'll tell
you this right now he'll [ __ ] your ass
up with a bow and arrow yeah I think I
know all the weapons I think I would
want to master it like a sword or
something
I'm going to use multiple tanks because
in an arrow a boner is like cool the
thing you run out of air literally is
it's the fact that if it if it hits you
it hit you here I mean like this like
seemed something I could dodge but look
how fast that is any proof that bow and
arrow like archers they were a good at
close combat too so if you have it right
here
we shoot you point-blank like in like
half a second doctor I bone out if you
don't really have to do much I know I
know I'm going to get you for Mother's
Day next year what is it three haystacks
that's hard game yeah I'm a bono finally
a good one I've been wanting a crossbow
for example anything no gun no this is
way better
Oh crossbows are even better you don't
even have to extend your own but there's
no skill of all so that's worth it let
me give you a better than crossbows
because the reloading thing is too slow
yep fine you should have given me a bone
ounce of a stupid good I'm gonna give
you a bone arrow never used oh my god if
you killed in a trigger with a bone oh
that's so [ __ ] good because you could
see where you hit them too just sticks
out with a flag oh okay guys pretty good
oh thank you it's my skill and it just
looks hot I know you just said it wasn't
efficient to do this thing but I want to
do that thing because it looks [ __ ]
badass
yeah it's like you leave your whole
torso exposed get me my scenario in the
movie they know where it's at but it
really like or like a little special
thing they put it on this side yeah but
it's like a straw when you're just like
it's like in the backyard you're just
like I've got it yeah I want to imagine
it it's it's better than that now there
was pretty close so when Megan she
sprang into action and they're saying
that she acted like a trained EMT
because and she immediately ordered like
one of her friends like you go get help
you give me the short you and I like
surge of giving that doll that I wonder
if I were to listen to her entire reason
what what would you do you know I know I
get that happen in my friend who clearly
isn't trained herself she like shut the
[ __ ] up I know what I'm doing I run away
and not help there's a big-ass gash on
her friend though I think I'll be like
I'm telling the teacher hmm or there's
no teacher I'm telling what I would do
is I would take the mud and I would put
it into the wounds that's intuitive
probably
probably though do you get squeamish is
like people's and rude
yes definitely you don't think you'd be
able to spring into action like this
well I think if someone's injured and if
you know what to do you just gotta do it
so I'd tie her leg up and cut it off
would you see that would you like you
know what it's too late haha let's give
I chopped it up okay
I saw this on Walking Dead we didn't
really have much time I take off the
shirt I can wrap around the arm and
waited it's just a broken wrist no
imagine if a young Joe was part like one
of the kids in Lord of the Flies how
[ __ ] up everything was really pretty
sure if Joe isn't Lord of the Flies
netbook would end well everybody's dead
you know it's just Joe it's [ __ ]
blood stress you're already eating
people in the first day
what are we gonna do I got Halloween
what's the craziest injury you guys seen
in person I mean I haven't invested in a
surgery not an injury though like like
in real life that's all that lots of
control setting it is yes no but that
dude his he refrigerator fell on his
middle finger the entire finger was like
first it opened yeah I mention I was a
kid and I was in my dad's a car we were
driving and we went past like a car
accident scene and I I'm pretty sure
what I saw was a guy laying on floor
with a pool of blood around him that's
pretty traumatizing and yeah that
probably crazy dangerous car accident
like you know when you draw AI corrupt
drive by and then you see like people
are bloody on the 110 there was a dude
he I don't know what happened per se but
[ __ ] his shirt here was all bloody
and you see this whole arm is just
[ __ ] red so I don't know what
happened to do but this arm was not
moving I'm a hundred percent sure at the
Adrenaline's gone he's a star screaming
I remember some crazy [ __ ] I thought so
Casey Isaac and I we all went to Knott's
Berry Farm and we were waiting in line
for this one right I forgot which right
it was the way the line is set up like
we have to go up these stairs
and then you can see the right right
we're climbing up the stairs and so
we're trying to speak over the wall to
see what what the commotion was about
and I saw his little kid he loves maybe
like about six or seven years old and
his butt was jammed between the car and
likes assignment oh I don't know what
I'm talking about
the actual car and the rail that's where
his foot levels but getting better so
apparently this kid when they were about
to stop because he already did the whole
life and when he was coming in to stop
he stuck his foot out I don't know why
but he stuck his foot out and that's
when I got caught and so I saw when they
retained his little boy out that his
entire soft was drenched oh my god I get
crushed I had some pretty bad so nasty
yeah I can visualize all of that what's
the military base in near San Diego
County Allison yeah so for some reason
there was a dude no ma'am I got a kernel
stuck in my teeth
colonel swagger my teeth I lost a short
guy ran into the middle of the freeway I
don't [ __ ] know where and it was it
was a military cat maybe from the
penalty if that's the military base I
was there and the guy just ran in the
middle of the freeway like into the
middle of the freeway and my cousin ran
him over
yeah you know I just think I died like
immediately Oh a lot everywhere in like
the kid that was in the cartoon was like
shaking because he was so traumatized
no screaming didn't think another
thinking but similar thing happened to
my cousin Mexico this homeless guy he
walked right in so he saw my cousin's
car coming in this one like curve near
the border it's like everyone goes
really fast in that curve and he just
saw like my cousin coming he walked he
ran in front of her car could die he
wanted the guy you know like she liked
her corner of hitting ham it was blood
all over the car the ambulance took the
guy away and then she wanted to find out
if he was dead or like what happened but
apparently the ambulance said we don't
know that guy because the guy thought he
just disappeared so we're thinking like
they were using his body for some other
stuff but maybe he was a superhero and
what happened was he's like a cat yeah
hope you guys enjoyed that episode if
you guys have any juicy little guts of
details and you guys want to submit it
well guess what you can cruise on over
to the description box below click on
the
wink submit the sort and hopefully we
will pick it and talk about it for more
videos click right over here
[Music]